let's bring in our U.S correspondent
Mark Stone joining us from DC and as I
mentioned there briefly Mark President
Biden arrives at a Time ahead of that
NATO leaders meeting where the United
States have made
what many see is a controversial
decision to supply cluster Munitions to
Ukraine
yes President Biden had said himself
that this decision
um was not an easy one to make and it's
clear from officials I've spoken to here
it's not a decision they wanted to make
but the facts on the ground in Ukraine
on those battlefields in the east of the
country are what they are and the amount
of ammunition of more conventional
artillery that is being used is it's
being used at such an extent that it has
surprised everyone the there is a sense
of stalemate the ukrainians counter
offenses offensive plainly is not going
as as quickly as people had hoped that's
not to say the Russians are doing any
better they are not but there is a
stalemate there and the ammunition is
running low and therefore it has become
clear that to bridge that Gap cluster
Munitions from the Americans need to be
part of the of the weapons package the
other NATO countries many other NATO
countries have expressed their own ease
when asked about this decision at
Britain Germany New Zealand Canada
others as well have been are worried
about this decision but they are bound
to say that because they're Bound by
Convent a convention Banning the use of
cluster Munitions which the Americans
never signed now countering that the
Americans have said quite clearly that
they believe uh that their their
specific cluster munition that they are
supplying to the ukrainians won't be
dropped from Planes indiscriminately it
will be fired from artillery pieces on
the battlefield it has what's known as a
very low dud rate in other words the big
concern with cluster Munitions is that
um they a proportion of the bomblets
that are distributed on on and out on
the area where the the munition lands do
not explode well the dud rate of the
Munitions the Americans are supplying is
is plus or minus two percent that is low
compared to the dud rate of the uh
weapons that the Ukraine the Russians
are already using on the battlefield and
the the sort of weapons that were used
in Wars like like Yugoslavia but this
weapon it is controversial it will cause
conversations at NATO but it is highly
effective on the battlefield and that is
where the ukrainians say it will be used
the onus will be on them to make sure
they don't hit civilians and to make
sure there isn't a legacy of Civilian
casualties
afterwards uh the as I say it is a very
effective weapon and the hope is that it
will break the the stalemate it was used
back in 1991 in in the Galt the first
Gulf War uh by the Americans and the
Iraqi uh military used to say it was
like steel rain uh coming down on their
Battlefield so you can get a sense of
how effective it is but also how
controversial it is if it is dropped as
the as the um Russians have been doing
in the wrong place absolutely uh Mark
for now thank you for that Mark
stonearion in DC
um with the news there that uh as
President Biden's Jets Air Force One
begins its taxi there is some
controversy surrounding his arrival in
the UK ahead of going on to a NATO
leaders Summit in illness in Lithuania
we've got our
political correspondent Rob Powell
standing by as well for some insight
into
the discussion that will be held
tomorrow between
President Biden and prime minister Rishi
sunaka and Rob this is going to be the
sick meeting between the two men the
last time they met they announced that
Atlantic declaration with a lot of
promises and plans to work more closely
together
um but as uh Mark was mentioning there
there is a bit of tension when the two
meet over those cluster Munitions yeah
lots of meetings already
um for these two leaders as you say they
were at the G7 they were also in
Washington when Richard sunac flew over
there to see Joe Biden last month they
met in San Diego as well to discuss that
defense Alliance and in Belfast of
course to discuss the Good Friday
agreement the anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement tomorrow morning there
will be a meeting
um between Rishi sunak and Joe Biden in
terms of what's expected to be discussed
while the pre-briefed remarks from
Downing streets suggests an emphasis on
that declaration that agreement that was
come to in Washington in the last visit
antic declaration that essentially is
sort of series of mini deals really
about
cooperation on clean energy on critical
minerals and artificial intelligence
about strengthening Supply chains as
well number 10 very very keen I think to
put that forward as a sign that even
though a sort of more formal trade deal
it appears completely off the table at
the moment they are working to try and
strengthen especially trade alliances
and cooperation with the US I think
though I was listening to an interview
with the the British Ambassador in
Washington earlier this weekend and she
described the original hook for this
visit from Joe Biden to the UK as
actually being an invitation from the
King because of course after that
meeting tomorrow in Downing Street Joe
Biden will head to Windsor Castle where
he will meet King Charles he of course
wasn't at the coronation of King Charles
so this will be the first time that he
has met him since he was crowned and I
think discussions there are expected to
focus on climate change and Joe Biden's
approach to Green policies and Green
Tech investment clearly for King Charles
that is a massive personal interest and
something that in the past the
Ambassador said anyway he had discussed
with Joe Biden um in the past we were
expecting as well according to the
schedule the briefing from the White
House that the president will also take
part in a climate engagement with the
King and also with philanthropists and
investors as well John Kerry President
Biden's Envoy for climate has been is
already in the UK giving interviews this
morning he said that he and the Energy
Secretary from the UK government grant
shafts were expected to brief the king
and the president as well tomorrow in
Windsor so I think a big part of this uh
yes the Rishi sunap meeting but as you
say there have been several before I
think maybe the sort of prime mover of
this trip will be that meeting with the
King where climate is set to take Center
Stage it's fascinating robbers we're
continuing to look at that's uh the door
there of Air Force One which is open the
steps are in place some of the officials
there preparing the moment when
President Biden does disembark and
begins his uh quick visit
a stop over in the UK before going on to
the NATO leader Summit let's bring back
in our U.S correspondent Mark Stone uh
if we can uh Mark as Rob was mentioning
there you know Biden and two neck have
met six times as we
see President Biden at the top of the
steps arriving here in the UK let's just
stay with these pictures a moment before
bringing mark back in
yeah
your President Biden there down the
steps uh on his shoulder the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blink and he
has been met by the U.S ambassador to
the United Kingdom Jane Hartley
President Biden and his team will spend
the evening at the ambassador's
residence that's in Regents Parker we're
told they're going to take Marine One to
get there and that will be taken to the
air shortly once President Biden has
glad handed and met all those officials
who
arrived at stansted's to meet him let's
bring Mark Stone back in our U.S
correspondent uh Mark just picking up on
the points that Rob was making there you
know we as we said President Biden and
prime minister sunac have met many times
six times this will be the sixth uh
meeting between the two men and there
was a that Atlantic declaration
announced last time they met in DC so
the importance then I guess uh Mark of
his meeting with the king in the first
meeting with the King since uh King
Charles was crown
yes and we're told that the two men the
king and the president have a good uh a
good relationship they don't know each
other all that well
um and this is as Rob said is the first
time that the president would have met
the king as king uh but both men um have
had long careers the president has met
uh then Prince Charles uh many times
over his uh many years as vice president
as a senator here in the United States
uh as well and so there is a
relationship there in the Rock there are
um Mutual interests as well climate
change being a key one and so I think um
as we see the President Ford Marine one
uh for that short flight from Stansted
uh to Wingfield house in Regents Park
um one of the focuses will be tomorrow
on climate change and on how the two men
um can um marry their interests on
climate change can use their influence
um on it on issues of climate change so
that will be a focus tomorrow afternoon
that we'll get all the pomp of course
with the well guards guard of honor at
Windsor Castle and the quadrangle there
at Windsor Castle before a meeting
between the king and the president in I
think the green drawing room of Windsor
Castle before that though there will be
the more substantive political
discussion uh with prime minister Rishi
sunak this will be the first time that
President Biden has been to number 10
Downing Street as president of course
he's been there many times before as
vice president but this is the first
time as president
um but the Americans and the Brits are
quite Keen to to quash any suggestions
that the uh the president is
anti-british there's been a a bit of a
narrative recently
um stemmed I think from um from an
American reluctance to to wants to put
forward Ben Wallace the current UK
defense secretary as a potential
successor to Yen stoltenberg at NATO the
Americans were not up for that that
generated some suggestions along with uh
the the president's um vibe in Ireland
when he visited Ireland that perhaps he
was anti-british they're trying to do as
much as they can to counter that and are
pointing out that the president and the
Prime Minister have met six times in the
last six months um they met in San Diego
over a deal with uh with submarines with
Australia they met just last month or um
here at the White House so so an awful
lot of meetings have taken place between
the two sides they would say that
special relationship is certainly
special still yeah they certainly would
say that okay Mark for now thank you
very much for that uh political
correspondent Rob Pyle is still standing
by as we looking at their at the
helicopter which has now become Marine
one now that the president is on board
as Mark was saying it's about to make
the short flight from stanston airport
just to the east of London to North West
London to Regions Park to Winfield house
the residence of the U.S ambassador and
Rob
um as President Biden begins that
Journey just pick up on a couple of the
thoughts that Mark was mentioning there
I mean the the next NATO sect to be
General was a a piece a piece of a
contention between the two groups but
that seems to have been resolved now but
do you think it could still come up I'm
not sure it would necessarily come up
formally in discussions between the two
men but I think it's right to say that
there's maybe a sort of bad taste left
in the mouths of um some on the UK side
we've had people like Jacob Reese MOG
back benches that are not necessarily a
fan of Richard sunac either talking
about the decayed state of the special
relationship there's also some concern I
think about President Biden's green
agenda in terms of the amount of money
he's putting into quite protectionist
measures to further U.S Green Tech I
think some on the UK side within the
party the conservative party concerned
about that I'm not sure though that
these are things that will necessarily
come up as substantive disagreements
though as Mark was saying I think both
sides you get to play down any uh chance
of a spat on this occasion known as such
a short visit they won't want to have a
falling out before both of them head off
to business for that NATO leaders Summit
we are looking looking at live pictures
now from Stansted Airport President
Biden has arrived in the UK for a quick
stop before going on to Vilnius in
Lithuania for a NATO leaders meeting he
is going to spend the evening at
Winfield house in regions part the
residents of the U.S ambassador before
tomorrow morning having a meeting with
prime minister Richie soon at plenty on
the agenda for those two men to talk
about it will be this this will be
another meeting they've already met six
times recently and then President Biden
will be meeting the king at Windsor
Castle President Biden arriving in the
UK for his visit
it is 10 o'clock you are watching Sky
News at 10. President Joe Biden has
arrived in the United Kingdom that is
Marine One at Stansted Airport President
Biden is here for a meeting with the
Prime Minister and with the king before
President Biden goes to a NATO leaders
meeting in filner's there is plenty on
the agenda for his discussion with the
Prime Minister Rishi sunat the two men
met recently in Washington DC where the
Atlantic Declaration was agreed to a
wide-ranging agreement with a number of
elements in terms of trade and
Deals over business relations and the
green agenda and also later in the day
tomorrow President Biden will be meeting
the king will be the first visit a first
meeting between President Joe Biden and
King Charles since King Charles was
crowners we watched Marine One begin its
taxi a short from Stanford airport to
across London to North West London to
the US ambassadors residents are U.S
correspondent Mark stone is standing by
for us and Mark we've sort of touched on
many of the issues we think that may
well come up between the two men
President Biden and prime minister sunak
when they eventually meet but of course
this is just a guess for President Biden
the a stopover because there is a very
substantive and important NATO leaders
meeting in Lithuania that he's in Europe
for later in the week
yes it's an alignment of schedules I
mean the king had invited the president
for a visit it's not an official state
visit and they worked out that it was
worthwhile doing it now on the way to
Vilnius to the summit uh the annual
Summit which is taking place uh later on
uh this week so I think at the uh at
Downing Street uh the morning meeting
with Richie sunac there will be a a
predominant focus on Ukraine on the
issue of Ukraine the decisions has then
cluster Munitions by the Americans
um to Ukraine at the membership of
Ukraine uh to Nato the membership of
Sweden to Nato as well these will be
will be key issues that will be
discussed tomorrow at Downing streets
and then as 31 countries they will be
discussed at the NATO Summit as well so
there is an awful lot of discussion that
will take place on an awful lot of
different issues as the war enters I
think it's 500 day now now there is a
sense of stalemate on the the Eastern
battlefields of Ukraine in a sense that
the that the counter-offensive by
Ukraine the so-called spring offensive
um is if not struggling then certainly
slow
um there was a hope if not an
expectation that it would be quicker
there is a shortage of ammunition I was
struck by how candid President Biden was
in an interview today on CNN before
going to London um he was he was clear
that Ukraine is fast running out of
artillery uh the stocks back here in the
United States we've been to factories
where we've seen them
making ammunition they two are running
out and so there are real there needs to
be real focusing of minds and I think
the U.S president will once again try
and persuade other NATO countries to
provide more Weaponry the Americans have
provided
um a Tron shaft a tranche of weapons to
Ukraine other countries Britain is
second I think to the U to the US in
providing Weaponry but other countries
are not doing as much as the Americans
and the British would like them to so
the Americans and the British are at one
on that issue they may have differences
over other issues they're at one on that
and I think one effort will be to
persuade other NATO countries
um to to provide more Weaponry as this
war goes on and on to break the uh the
stalemate and to push Russia back out of
Ukrainian uh territory I mentioned the
membership of Sweden to Nato uh that is
uh very very important it's something
that most NATO countries would like to
see happen immediately it's being held
up by turkey who have issues over uh
Sweden's view on on Turkish separatists
Kurdish separatists um in Turkey so
that's an issue the hungarians have an
issue with Swedish membership to make
NATO as well so that needs to be ironed
out the expectation of conversations
I've had that will probably be ironed
out the other bigger issue is a
membership of Ukraine to Nato down the
line that won't happen now but because
Ukraine does not at the moment meet the
criteria to be a NATO member and also if
it was to become a NATO member now it
would create huge complications because
it would effectively invoke Article 5 of
NATO which is if one country is attacked
then all of them are attacked well
Ukraine is already being attacked so
they can't bring Ukraine into NATO now
but I think we will get a form of
language a communique as it's known a
statement of intent that yes NATO
Ukraine should be part of NATO at some
point after the war has come to an end